[Applaus]
[Musik]
hört euch bitte machen das folgende
statement der sozialdemokratischen
schwedischen ministerpräsidentin bank
arena anders sondern denn es hat so
manchen aus denen es umgehauen
schwedische ministerpräsident gesagt die
integration von einwanderern sei
gescheitert und habe die
bandenkriminalität angeheizt die
integration war zu schlecht während er
gleichzeitig eine große einwanderung
hatten die gesellschafter zu schwach die
mittel für die polizei und die sozialen
dienste waren zu gering die segregation
wolle so weit getrieben dass in schweden
parallelgesellschaften entstanden sind
wir leben im selben land aber in völlig
unterschiedlichen realitäten und
darlehen an das schwedische
ministerpräsidentin mal sehen wir haben
hier also eines sozialdemokratische
regierungschefin die aktuell noch an der
macht ist und derartige aussagen über
einwanderung von sich gibt damit folgt
sie ihrer dänischen kollegin mette
friedrichs m ebenfalls sozialdemokrat in
libera cindy januar 2021 verkündet hatte
dass die zuwanderung stark begrenzt
werden sollte um den sozialen
zusammenhalt der ohnehin schon
angespannten dänischen gesellschaft
nicht noch weiter zu gefährden
[Musik]
auch sie betonte dass die zahl der
migranten einen starken einfluss auf die
integration der zuwanderer habe in der
praxis bedeutete dies dass die regierung
aktiv gegen die anti demokratischen
werte vorgehen würde die in dänemark
folgen die kranken aus muslimischen
ländern praktiziert würde es scheint
ganz so als wäre sowohl im staate
dänemark als auch schweben so einiges
äußerst voll geworden aber natürlich ist
das alles für schweden weitaus
ungewöhnlicher als für dänemark dass
seine integrations regelung und bereits
in den 2010er jahren verschärft hatte
schweden hingegen hielt sich lange mit
seiner ultra lockeren
einwanderungspolitik für ein großes
vorbild und war sehr stolz darauf eines
der ersten länder der welt zu sein doch
nun mussten auch die schweden die
notbremse ziehen und werden wohl ihren
nachbarn folgen auf welche unhaltbaren
zustände genau bezieht sich also die
schwedische premier ministerin und warum
sind die integrationsprobleme von
einwanderern nach einer langen zeit des
wegschauens plötzlich doch noch in den
fokus der ganzen nation gerückt was ist
in schweden eigentlich los das alles
nehmen wir heute unter die lupe
daten
[Musik]
schaut euch die folgenden zahlen genau
an im jahr 2021 wurden in schweden 335
schusswechsel registriert bei denen die
41 menschen ums leben kam ja es stimmt
verglichen mit den usa oder
lateinamerika mögen diese zahlen die ein
bis vorkommen fast wie eine glückselig
friedliche utopie selbst wenn wir die
unterschiede in der bevölkerungszahl
berücksichtigen sind die daten unendlich
viel besser als das was in den
vereinigten staaten oder praktisch jeden
lateinamerikanischen land jedes jahr
abgeht allein in den usa kamen im jahr
2020 mehr als 23.000 menschen durch
tötungsdelikten schießrain ums leben wir
reden hier über völlig unterschiedliche
szenarien im europäischen vergleich sind
die schwedischen statistiken jedoch
bemerkenswert
schweden ist das land in europa in dem
die schusswaffen kriminalität am
stärksten zunimmt und es hat eine der
höchsten mordraten wäre den schweden zum
beispiel durchschnittlich vier
todesfälle pro million einwohner und
jahr durch schusswaffen zu beklagen sind
die europäische durchschnitt bei nur 1,6
außerdem steigt der trend in schweden
anders als im restlichen europa immer
noch steigt an all das bedeutet zum
beispiel dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ein mann im alter zwischen 15 und
29 jahren erschossen wird ihr schweden
preis jetzt zehnmal höher ist als in
deutschland
schweden steht laut bericht bei
tödlichen schusswechsel an der spitze
europas in weniger als einem jahrzehnt
hat schweden italien und osteuropäischen
länder überholte und die höchste zahl an
tödlichen schießereien in europa
verzeichnet aber das ist noch nicht
alles im jahr 2019 würden in ganz
schweden 2 160 straftaten mit
sprengstoff registriert was einem
anstieg von 60 prozent gegenüber vorjahr
entspricht gesprächen von bomben und
sprengsätze die oft im öffentlichen raum
gezündet werden meist vor wohnanlagen
und in kleinen unternehmen
das klingt eher nach einer kriegszone
als nach bullerbü geld und wenn wir noch
bedenken dass schweden die höchste rate
an vergewaltigungen und sexueller gewalt
in europa und das hass verbrechen gegen
minderheiten die personen mit lg
background ebenfalls zu nehmen für das
bild sehr sehr deutlich offensichtlich
hat schweden ein gewaltiges problem mit
gewalt
[Musik]
überraschenderweise ist die allgemeine
schwedische kriminalitätsrate jedoch
nicht was und das hoch sondern liegt im
europäischen durchschnitt wenn wir alle
übrigen verbrechens arten
berücksichtigen und genau deshalb müssen
sich die schweden in europa mit abstand
den meisten sorgen um kriminalität in
ihrem land machen für sie ist es bereits
die hauptsorge nummer eins das erklärt
auch warum setzt die sozialdemokraten
unter ministerpräsidentin manchmal
anders und nicht mehr in der lage sind
dieses problem wie bislang gewohnt
herunterzuspielen
aber die frage die sich jetzt viele von
euch stellen lautet sicher was zum
teufel ist in schweden genau los wie um
alles in der welt lässt sich solch eine
welle der gewalt erklären nun an den
meisten schusswechsel und explosionen
schweden sind organisierte
verbrecherbanden beteiligt
18 schießereien haben in dem nordischen
land irgendetwas mit kriminellen banden
zu tun das problem das am meisten anlass
zur sorge gibt ist das mehr als die
hälfte nämlich 53 prozent der zu
gefängnisstrafen verurteilten im ausland
geboren wurden dieser prozess ist steigt
auf fast 90 prozent derjenigen die
verdächtigt werden in schießereien
verwickelt zu sein wenn wir sowohl im
ausland geborene täter als auch die
zweite generation von einwanderern mit
einbeziehen liebe visual politik
zuschauer natürlich haben wir in diesem
video nicht die absicht mit dem finger
auf jemanden wegen seiner herkunft zu
zeigen ihr wisst dass der stets für
dinge wie freizügigkeit stehen und immer
wieder betonen dass migrationsbewegungen
ein starker motor für wohlstand freiheit
gut immer situation sind aber eben nur
solange die dinge richtig gehandhabt
werden und nicht aus dem ruder geraten
deshalb sollten wir in diesem video
faktoren aufzeigen die eine effektive
integration behindern können die so
unterscheidet sich die situation in
schweden derart radikal negativ von der
in ländern wie australien neuseeland
oder gar den usa nun erinnert ihr euch
noch an die schlagzeile vom anfang des
videos
schwedische ministerpräsident sagt die
integration von einwanderern sei
gescheitert und habe die
bandenkriminalität angeheizt genau das
ist der erste punkt aber um die ganze
situation zu verstehen müssten wir uns
ein paar weitere frage stellen ist der
anstieg der gewaltverbrechen in schweden
wirklich nur die schulter einwanderer
welche verantwortung tragen die behörden
und die politiker wobei genau hat
schweden eigentlich versagt und was kann
es jetzt noch tun ist eine kehrtwende
überhaupt noch möglich
[Musik]
eine monokausale sicht
in schweden gibt es eine
schlüsselkomponente die einwanderung und
kriminalität miteinander verbindet die
soziale ausgrenzung aber wo manchmal
bevor einige von euch laut aufschreien
nein wir werden euch nicht die übliche
geschichte erzählen dass kriminalität
und radikalisierung ausschließlich durch
armut begründet sind und die lösung des
hat darin bestünde einfach noch mehr
geld für sozialhilfe subventionen aller
art auszugeben denn wenn es in schweden
irgendwas im überfluss gibt das ist
gerade staatliche beihilfen und
subventionen für die problemgruppen und
auch wenn es auf den ersten blick absurd
erscheinen mag könnte gerade dieser
überfluss an öffentlichen mitteln eine
erklärung für den tsunami an ausgrenzung
und qualität seien in denen der
skandinavischen land erlebt hat das
sagen übrigens nicht nur wir auch die
sozialdemokratische ministerpräsidentin
selbst scheint sich mittlerweile darüber
im klaren zu sein
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass in schweden die
zugewanderten bevölkerung enorme
öffentliche hilfen aller art erhält vor
allem wenn es sich um asylsuchende
handelt aber wenn es eine leistung gibt
die sich von allen anderen abhebt dann
sind es die kinderzulagen diese
sozialleistungen gibt es natürlich nicht
nur für einwanderer im jahr nutzte 82
als in schweden die geburtenrate ist
sehr niedrig war wurde eine reihe von
sozialleistungen eingeführt und familien
ein großzügiges einkommen zu bieten wenn
sie kinder bekommen und nein wir
sprechen hier nicht von einem einmaligen
baby bonus das ganze feld erstmal
unverdächtig mit den regelmäßigen
kindergeld an dass eltern mit wohnsitz
in schweden ab dem monat nach der geburt
ihres kindes erhalten bis 16 jahre alt
wird unter bestimmten umständen kann
diese beiden versuche verlängert werden
bis das geht 20 jahre alt ist was bietet
der schwedische staat also für jedes
kind nun im grunde einen zuschuss von
mindestens 1250 kronen das sind zwar 120
euro pro monat und wisst ihr was die
zugewanderten bevölkerung hat im
durchschnitt viel mehr kinder als sie
alt eingesessene so dass diese
leistungen vor allem ihr zugute kommen
aber wie gesagt mit dem kindergeld fängt
das ganze erst an denn darüber hinaus
gibt ist auch viele andere bestimmungen
dieses und das begünstigen
da wären zum beispiel vorteile beim
zugang zur sozialwohnungen vor allem
wenn die preise in die höhe schießen und
es keine andere möglichkeit gibt eine
wohnung zu finden großzügige
mietzuschüsse für kinderreiche familien
direkte geldleistungen für asylbewerber
und so weiter und so fort die zahl der
vielen sozialprogramme ist fast
unüberschaubar groß und natürlich werden
sich jetzt viele von euch die frage
stellen aber mag was das an alldem denn
falsch ein starker sozialstaat ist doch
eine gute sache mit der armut
ungleichheit und ausgrenzung bekämpft
werden sollen habt ihr uns nicht im
vorletzten video groß von den
ungarischen familien förderprogramme
vorgeschwärmt andy der dortige statt 4,8
prozent seines bip investiert wieso
sollte etwas was in ungarn gut ist
entscheidend wirklich schlecht sein was
hat das mit dem problem zu tun über die
wir in diesem video sprechen nun wie ihr
wisst sind wir ja eigentlich keinen
großen fans von autoritarismus aller
orban dafür aber große fans von freiheit
gleichheit armutsbekämpfung emanzipation
und integration und beim vergleich
dieser beiden länder muss man einfach
ganz klar erkennen das sozialprogramm
nur in kombination mit weiteren
wichtigen faktoren zu diesen positiven
effekten führen wenn diese faktoren das
fehlen und man nichts dagegen unternimmt
das sich sogar eine reihe negativer
rahmenbedingungen immer weiter verstärkt
erreicht man ihnen das genaue gegenteil
dessen wofür sie eigentlich da sind
nämlich unfreiheit ungleichheit
unterdrückung und ausgrenzung und das
sogar bis zu jenem punkt in dem diese
dinge in extreme gewalt ausarten und zu
einer partiellen zusammenbruch der
gesellschaft führen können gut aber
lasst uns an dieser stelle doch die
genauen mechanismen unter die lupe
nehmen damit dies alles nicht nur eine
behauptung bleibt und wer konstruktiv
aus den fehlern der schweden lernen
können natürlich handelt es sich um ein
sehr komplexes thema mit vielen
kulturellen faktoren aber wenn wir alles
herunter brechen bleibende im grunde
immer bei einer ganz bestimmten fatalen
entwicklung hängen all dieses programm
haben direkte negative auswirkungen auf
den arbeitsmarkt dies liegt vor allem
daran dass ein sehr großer teil der
einwanderer die öffentliche hilfe nicht
nur als vorübergehende ressourcen muss
um wieder auf die beine zu kommen und
danach wieder einen positiven beitrag
zur gesellschaft leisten zu können
hierzu fehlt ihnen in vielen fällen
einfach die notwendige motivation zb
eine die situation mit den immateriellen
werten schwedens und noch einmal das
kommt nicht nur von uns die
beschäftigungsdaten weisen ganz klar auf
diesen umstand hin
das augenfälligste und deutlichste an
diese daten ist dass es am schlimmsten
die frauen trifft denn bei ihnen
erschwert die sozialhilfe in besonderem
maße sowohl die eingliederung in den
arbeitsmarkt als auch die soziale
integration die für manche kulturen
ohnehin schon sehr kompliziert ist laut
eurostat liegt in schweden zb die
beschäftigungsquote der im ausland
geborenen frauen fast 20 prozentpunkte
unter der quote der im land geborenen
frauen andererseits fördern die
sozialleistungen auch vollkommen falsche
anreize und eine illusorische
wirtschaftliche stabilität die viele
begünstigte dazu veranlasst sich keine
reguläre arbeit zu suchen um die
sozialhilfe nicht zu verlieren das
sozialsystem übertüncht dabei nicht nur
die realität der leistungs und
bildungsarmut ganzer communitys man
fördert auch noch die verfestigung
dieser gesellschaftlich und
volkswirtschaftlich destruktiven
struktur
es entstehen regelrechte informelle
netzwerke deren zweck einzig und allein
in der abschöpfung staatliche hilfen
besteht und es waren diese netzwerke
welche letztendlich die gründerin
entwicklung von kriminellen gruppen und
banken begünstigt haben um die dimension
des scheiterns der schwedischen
einwanderungspolitik zu verdeutlichen in
den usa und neuseeland haben zuwanderer
eine höhere beschäftigungsquote als die
einheimische bevölkerung selbst und in
australien und kanada beträgt der
unterschied zu gunsten der einheimischen
bevölkerung nur 3,4 bzw 1,7
prozentpunkte in schweden hingegen
beträgt der unterschied fast 15 punkte
mit anderen worten wir reden hier über
eine unhaltbare situation und das ist
noch nicht alles
in dem die schwedische kombination aus
einwanderungs und sozialpolitik die
beschäftigungsquote senkt und viele
zuwanderer davon abhält sich um einen
legalen vollzeit job zu bemühen da es
sich auch ihren integrationsgrad ihre
berufliche kompetenz und reduziert ihren
kontakt zum rest der gesellschaft wurde
zusammen mit der total fehl geleiteten
öffentlichen wohnungspolitik ergibt sich
ein perfekter cocktail für die
entstehung von ghettos einem umfeld das
die entwicklung von banken besonders
begünstigt so gibt es alleine stockholm
schätzungsweise 60 organisierte
verbrecherbanden die in der ganzen stadt
aktiv sind ob diese verfahrene situation
stellt sich natürlich die frage ob es
für all das überhaupt noch eine lösung
gibt welche folgen diese politik hat und
was genau das sozialdemokratische
schweden nun zu tun gedenkt ja wie so
oft führt eine schlechte politik nicht
nur zu schlechten ergebnissen sondern
manchmal auch zu schlecht und antworten
oder zumindest zu unzureichende
antworten
von einem extrem ins andere ohne klare
richtung
ganz plötzlich verändert sich schweden
und zwar in einem rasanten tempo auch
wenn die regierung immer noch in den
händen sozialdemokratischer politiker
ist aber geht der wandel überhaupt in
die richtige richtung nun das ist die
eigentlich interessante debatte denn
wäre schweden bis vor kurzem noch ein
beispiel für ein land der totalen
willkommenskultur war könnte die
gesellschaftliche und politische
reaktion heutzutage dazu führen dass die
drum antagonistische und feindselige
bewegungen überhand nehmen sich zudem
einen chaos ein weiteres hinzu gesellt
wäre schweden zum beispiel 2015 das land
war das im verhältnis zu seiner
bevölkerung mit abstand die meisten
syrischen flüchtlinge bzw all jene die
sich dafür ausgegeben haben aufgenommen
hat und jegliche kritik daran schon im
keim mit brutal nach sie colin erstickt
wurde sehen die schlagzeilen bezüglich
der stichwörter einwanderung und
schweden heute nur sieben jahre später
vollkommen anders aus selbst schweden
keine migranten mehr jetzt will sogar
die sozialdemokratische regierung selbst
ein neues einwanderungsgesetz einführen
das angeblich die ursache für alle
probleme bekämpfen soll das neue
schwedische migrations gesetz erschwert
flüchtlingen und ausländischen besuchern
den dauerhaften aufenthalt mit dem neuen
gesetz würden menschen aus dem ausland
nicht mehr so einfach sein nach schweden
einzuwandern oder zugang zu sozialhilfe
zu bekommen auch wird es nicht mehr
möglich sein ohne vertrag eine
arbeitserlaubnis zu erhalten außerdem
muss man mindestens drei jahre in
schweden gelebt haben um anspruch auf
eine dauerhafte aufenthaltserlaubnis zu
haben und es wird der nachweis des
mindesteinkommens von 810 euro pro monat
verlangt damit passt sich schweden zwar
nur den gesetzen fast alle anderen
europäischen länder an der punkt ist
jedoch dass in diesem fall das
ultimative ziel lautet generell die zahl
der einwanderer drastisch zu reduzieren
ohne das differenzierte und intelligente
filterkriterien zum einsatz kommen wie
zum beispiel in den usa australien
neuseeland oder kanada und das ist ein
gewaltiges problem denn schweden hat
eigentlich schon jetzt viel weniger
einwanderung als dieser länder es geht
in erster linie also nicht um quantität
und qualität aber darauf hat die
sozialdemokratische regierung von
magdalena anders und keine kompetente
antwort liefert sie hat eine
undifferenzierte 180 grad der ende
einwanderungspolitik des landes
hingelegt und bearbeitet das problem
lieber mit dem stumpfen holzhammer
anstatt die eigenen lebenslügen und
tabus die erste ganzen misere geführt
haben konstruktiv aufzuarbeiten denn
dies würde wohl einen noch größeren
gesichtsverlust für ihr politisches
lager bedeuten
was sich vorerst nichts ändern wird ist
daher das umfangreiche subventions und
sozialsystem dass jegliche
leistungsanreize erstickt zu einer
krassen die emanzipation von frauen wie
auch männern führt und darüber hinaus
genau jene migranten ansieht welche
dieses system ausnutzen wollen auch eine
wohnungsbaupolitik welche die bildung
von ghettos behindern würde ist weit und
breit nicht zu erkennen das sind
gegenteil die sozialdemokratische
regierung und magdalene anders und will
noch mehr geld zur verfügung stellen
ohne sich um relevante fragen wie das
beschäftigungsniveau den
unternehmergeist soll die einstellung
der ausländischen bevölkerung gegenüber
demokratischen humanistischen und
freiheitlichen werten zu kümmern dabei
sind es genau diese faktoren die neben
bildung den schlüssel zur förderung der
integration darstellen
sie sind absolut notwendig wenn schweden
eine freie aufgeklärt und
leistungsfähige gesellschaft bleiben
möchte und natürlich eine soziale denn
ohne die erstgenannten bedingungen ist
langfristig auch kein sozialstaat
finanzierbar also das problem ist nicht
die corus zahl der einwanderer in
schweden sondern ihre auswahl in
kombination mit dem ineffizienten
kontraproduktiven jahr
gesellschaftlichen system von
sozialleistungen und subventionen aller
art ohne eine wirklich offene ehrliche
und differenzierte gesellschaftliche und
politische debatte über die
zusammensetzung und mentalität von
wandergruppen und wie die politik diese
positiv oder negativ beeinflussen kann
laufen die schweden gefahr die gesamte
ausländische bevölkerung zu
kriminalisieren ohne wirklich etwas
gutes zu erreichen
[Musik]
es geht dabei sowohl um die mentalität
der einwanderer als auch die der
einheimischen wenn sich erst daran
gewöhnt haben von letzteren ihre endlose
alimentierung einfordern zu können und
letztere nicht von ersteren ultimativ
fordern sich endlich in die
funktionierenden gesellschaftlichen
strukturen einzugliedern verfestigt sich
zwischen beiden seiten ein extrem
ungesundes und polarisieren das
ungleichgewicht welche schließlich zum
sozial- und gesellschaftlichen kollaps
führen wird wenn schweden wie wir es
gekannt haben überleben will darf es
daher keine förderung mehr ohne
forderungen geben eine reaktion der
regierung die darin besteht einwanderung
generell die schuld zu geben mit
gesetzlichen änderungen die zahl der
migranten extrem zu drosseln und dann
diejenigen die schon da sind mit noch
mehr geld zu überschütten scheint
langfristig für niemanden sehr
zielführend zu sein egal wie viele
stimmen diese populistischen wohltaten
für die regierungspartei einbringen denn
schwedens problem sind nicht die
einwanderung schon gar nicht die
fehlenden sozialleistungen die sind zum
beispiel gemessen am bip um 52 prozent
höher als in australien alles deutet
also darauf hin dass das problem genau
das gegenteil dessen ist was die
sozialdemokratische regierung zuzugeben
bereit ist aber was man mit ihr nach
allem was er gesehen habt glaubt ihr
dass schwedens wahres problem wirklich
die einwanderung generell ist oder ist
es stattdessen die sozialpolitik wie
sieht es in eurem land aus wird auch
dort eher pauschal ii polarisiert und
mit dem holzhammer gearbeitet oder sind
bereits ansätze intelligenter und
nachhaltiger
migrationspolitik erkennbar wie immer
sind doch eure angeregte diskussion zu
diesen kontroversen thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und vielleicht auch
etwas dabei gelang es ja gibt es mit
einleitete freuen und vergesse ich das
aber mit glöckchen keines unserer videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine spende von
alice projekte weiterzuführen dem paper
link dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]